the hotly anticipated shadow and bone
introduces the lavish fantasy world of
the grishaverse from dark villains to
chosen ones shadow monsters to magical
mcguffins and a charismatic crew of
hustlers thrown in for good measure
yipikaya movie lovers i'm jan and in
this video i'm breaking down everything
you need to know about shadow and bone
that final shot of the darkling and all
the clues to what you can expect in
season two for alina mal and the crows
spoilers ahead of course so take care
dominating the world of shadow and bone
is the fold a giant area of darkness
created by the darkling hundreds of
years before the main events of the show
and which split the powerful nation of
ravka in two
at the time the darkling was the rafkin
king's military advisor and had used his
grisha powers to help the king win a war
however when the king became fearful of
the darklings desire for more power he
put a bounty on his head
after the king's soldiers finally
tracked down the darkling he turned to a
form of forbidden magic known as merzost
once used by his forefather ilya
moritzova the grisha only practice the
small science which they define as the
manipulation of matter which already
exists and because it doesn't involve
conjuring or creating something from
nothing
they don't consider it magic strictly
speaking the use of murzust for the work
of creation on the other hand is much
more dangerous and unstable so although
the darkling's intention was only to
transform the king's soldiers into his
own army he lost control of the magic
and ended up creating the shadowfold
as the merzost escaped it transformed
the ordinary human beings who lived in
the area of the fold into monsters known
as volkra
which now roam the shadow world
threatening and attacking anyone who
enters or attempts to pass through
several hundred years later in the
present time of the show
the darkling who now goes by the name
general kirigan leads ravika's second
army which is made up entirely of grecia
although he appeared to create the fold
accidentally its existence has made
rafka dependent on the grecia and their
powers to help traverse the dangerous
roots through the fold
fight your time until there's a problem
only greisha can solve then the king
must embrace us
so when alina starkv discovers her son's
summoner powers with the ability to
destroy vulkra kirrigan takes a special
interest in her
he takes her to the little palace to
train and develop her powers which she
was unaware existed
kiragan claims he wants to use her to
help destroy the fold and free ravka
from its curse
at the palace alina ends up becoming
romantically interested in kiragan until
his mother bagra reveals the truth about
who he really is
and explains he's obsessed with finding
moritz over stag
a potent amplifier that will increase
his power dramatically
alina flees and after a brief encounter
with the crows she ends up reuniting
with mal and together they track down
the stag themselves
ever since she was a child alina has had
dreams of the stag and we can see the
connection she has with the magical
animal
when she touches it and it amplifies her
power kirrigan and his grisha however
interrupt this moment and he kills a
poor creature with the curt
the lethal blade he can summon from
darkness kirrigan then has david perform
a bonding ritual
that fuses the stag's antlers onto
alina's body while tethering her to
kirrigan giving him control over her
powers and the ability to turn them on
and off as he pleases
you could have made me your equal
instead you made me this with alina
under his control
kirigan puts into motion the final step
of his plan
and uses her son's summoner powers to
create a safe tunnel for him in a group
of foreign emissaries to travel through
the fold
alina then asks kirigan to use her to
destroy the fold as he once said he
would
why would we destroy the fold it's the
greatest weapon that we've got
in a lethal demonstration of the power
he now wields he expands the shadow fold
beyond its current position to consume
the city of novo krabiesk
right on the folds borders as the
darkness and vulkra consumed the city
kirrigan rids himself of general zlatan
the western rafkin independence leader
who threatened the unity of rafka and
ordered alina's assassination
with this gruesome display of power
kerrigan demands the foreign ambassadors
on the skiff
submit to his demands to end their wars
with ravka with the power of the sun
summoner at my command
i control the fold and its monsters i
can move it
to any border i like all countries will
answer to us
mal and the crows intervene with anesh
almost killing kirigan as she shoots a
knife into his chest
the darkling however calls on his
merzost powers which seem to be one of
the reasons he's immortal
and pulls out the knife tossing it aside
alina then has a vision of moritzov's
stag again and seeing the knife to her
side
she uses it to stab kirrigan through the
hand which slices off the wedge of skin
melded onto his wrist that was keeping
her tethered to him it's a striking
moment
as alina regains autonomy over both her
own body and her abilities as a sun
summoner
your first words to me well what are you
this
is what i am
kiragan can't understand how alina now
has control over the amplifier
because he killed the stag so he says
that he should have control over it
which is what the legends about
moritzov's creatures say they learned
killing one of these beasts and then
melding a piece of it into their body
would amplify their abilities
alina explains though that it was a
stag's choice to give her the power
this is presumably down to alina's
connection with the stag that she'd
already established throughout her life
and perhaps the fact she chose not to
kill the animal when she found it
i didn't understand before but i do now
you cannot claim what was not given to
you
the stag chose me proving her point the
antlers which until now have been
crudely melded onto her body
are now absorbed into her as the stag
seems to become one with alina
a convenient practical detail when it
comes to prosthetics and vfx for future
seasons of the show as well
this isn't the last we've seen of moritz
over as amplifiers though and there are
at least two more to appear in future
seasons
more on those very shortly kerrigan is
still alive of course
and although he ends up hauled off by a
vulkra during his fight with mal
the final shot of the season reveals he
survived this something not that
surprising given his own mother
described him as eternal
we can see he's been wounded badly with
some deep scars on his face though i'm
sure he could find a grisha healer for
these at some point
but more significantly emerging from the
fold are some new evil looking shadow
creatures
these are niche voyager also known as
nothings and are another creation of the
darklings merzost powers
these are a different kind of beast to
the vulcara as they can pass outside the
fold and i expect we'll see kirrigan use
these monsters against alina and mao
when he tracks them down in season two
unaware that kirigin is still alive
elena mao the crows and zoya plan their
next steps
alina is concerned she'll be blamed for
the destruction of novokrabiesk and zoya
says the apparat who's now pulling the
strings at the royal palace since the
king's poisoning will blame everything
on the grisha again
and asks alina to find new allies this
is setting up season 2 of alina's
storyline which if it stays close to the
books more or less like the first season
should see alina and mao travel across
the true sea
in search of another of moritz over as
amplifiers that selena
already learned about from the apparat
earlier in the show it all began with
this man one of the first creature in
recorded history
the bone smith book readers will know
that the bone smith's real name is ilya
moritzova
he was bagra's father and therefore the
darkling's grandfather
the bone smith was obsessed with
creating amplifiers that could boost
degrisha's powers as the apparat
explains
made creatures misum single bones
mythical animals brimming with
power attuned only to grisham we can see
moretz over stag on this page the first
amplifier that elena has already
acquired
but there are two other important
creatures the sea whip and the firebird
that we can expect to show up in
subsequent
seasons of the show the sea whip like
the stag is a legendary beast from
rafkin folklore and is said to be a
dragon prince cursed to live as a sea
serpent in what is known as the bone
road we got a hint that elena will be
headed to those icy waters in season two
in one of the books she picks up at the
library the bone road ebbs and the bone
road flows
once caught or killed the sea whip
scales can be used to create a feta or a
bracelet that when worn around the wrist
will amplify agrecia's powers
notice how alina turns her wrist in the
same scene foreshadowing the second
amplifier that we can expect to see her
wear in season two
the third amplifier that moritzova is
said to have created is a firebird
something that probably won't be seen
until the third season or later
however there is another possible living
amplifier that the show may already be
hiding in plain sight alina's childhood
friend
mal there's been several scenes hinting
that mao may have some latent powers and
that he's even more crucial to lena's
destiny than we might imagine although
everyone including mal seems to assume
he's not grecia we know he wasn't tested
on the day that grisha came to the
orphanage because he was injured so we
don't have conclusive proof about that
and if you re-watch carefully the scene
when alina discovers her son's summoner
powers for the first time
this occurs while she's holding hands
with mal which is of course similar to
how kirigan helped delena activate her
power by taking hold of her hand when
she was at the rafkin court to
demonstrate her abilities
from that scene we know that kirigan is
a living amplifier which suggests that
mal may be one too
and that it was his touch which
activated alina's powers for the first
time
notice also how mal and alina hold hands
as children when they're hiding to avoid
doing the grisha test
and then at the end of the second
episode there's a moment where the pair
seem to be able to sense each other even
though they're miles apart
that sixth sense in connection with
elena seems to be what helps him find
moritz over stag when he's tracking it
as he explains in the letter he writes
to her during his expedition to find the
mythical creature
when you lit up kirigan's tent there was
a sound a high tone
i knew it was you when we were kids
you'd hold my hand and sometimes i'd
hear it in the back of my head
then i hear that sound again softly
calling to me the show's clearly hinting
that there's something particularly
special about mao's tracking abilities
which i expect we'll see him use to find
the sea whip in season two
and by the way if mal truly does have a
special connection with moritz over
amplifiers it implies there's a lot more
to his past and heritage than his
orphanage upbringing might suggest
i'll talk more about some other easter
eggs you might have missed in the first
season in my next shadow and bone video
i'll add a link here and in the video
description as soon as it's ready
of course we also have to talk about the
crows kaz inez and jasper who in the
book grisha verse don't show up until a
few years after the main events of the
shadow and bone trilogy
what the tv show has done therefore is
to create a prequel story for the crow's
characters
in which we discover they were involved
in an attempted heist to kidnap the sun
summoner
that obviously didn't work out for them
however they leave alina and mao on good
enough terms at the end
and although their paths don't cross in
the book grisha verse
as the tv shows its own thing we may
well see them meet again in the future
what we do know is that at the end of
the first season the crows are heading
back to ketterdam where both dreesen and
pekka rollins await them
kaz says he has a plan for dealing with
them that requires a heart render and
what are the chances but sitting right
by them and overhearing their
conversation is nina agresha with that
exact skill set
nina is on the boat with her former
enemy turned lover mathias who's in
chains now and destined for the hellgate
prison in ketadam after nina found
herself forced to accuse him of being a
slaver so he wouldn't be taken away by
the grisha
in the six of crow's book kaz anez
jesper and nina team up together with
another character we haven't seen yet
called wylan for a heist to break out a
scientist being held prisoner in fyoda
in the novel they also need mathias to
do this so break him out of hell gate
prison
assuming then the show at least roughly
follows the plot of the six of crows
duology
we can expect to see him reunited with
nina showrunner eric heiser and
grishaverse author lee bardugo who's a
producer on the show
at the time of making this video haven't
confirmed whether they'll continue to
combine the crow's ongoing storyline
with the shadow and bone characters in
future seasons or whether the crows
could get their own separate spin-off
show set in the same
universe you stick with us everybody
gets what they want either way i think
the crows will be a hit with the fans
thanks to the heist action and humor
they bring to the story
what did we learn people with trains are
evil you can't kidnap a human
sunbeam true wealth is the friends
you make along the way so what did you
think of the first season of shadow and
bone and do you have any theories on
what will happen next
comment with your thoughts below and if
you enjoyed this then a thumbs up would
be hugely appreciated
and you can tap left to discover all the
easter eggs and book connections you
might have missed in season 1
or tap right for something else you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time yippee kai movie lovers
you